avant que la vidéo commence sachez qu'un
nouveau concours in stone gaming est
lancé pour participer c'est très simple
il vous suffit d'accéder aux liens du
concours disponibles dans la description
et de rentrer le nom du jeu que vous
aimeriez avoir et c'est tout bonne
chance à tous une bande-annonce des
éternels vient d'être dévoilée et nous
avons enfin quelque chose à nous mettre
sous la dent je vous propose qu'on
analyse ce trailer et par extension
grâce à ce dernier détail et des détails
cachés des bouts d'histoire des morceaux
d'origine des éternels allez c'est parti
tout d'abord nous faisons face à
l'arrivée des éternels sur la terre ce
qui correspond dans l'histoire du mc
hugh au tout début de l'existence des
héros ces derniers ont été créés par les
célestes des êtres cosmique dont les
origines sont encore floues ils sont là
depuis la naissance de l'univers
ils ont été mentionnés brièvement
pendant les gardiens de la galaxie par
le collectionneur et nous savons que i
go le père de quinn en était un
bref les célestes ont créé les éternels
pour que ces derniers soient les
protecteurs de la terre mission qui dans
les comics démarre il ya des centaines
de milliers d'années mais qui dans une
réadaptation pour le mc il serait dans
les trente cinq mille ans avant
aujourd'hui nous sommes donc face à
l'arrivée des éternels depuis lors
iconique vaisseau en forme triangulaire
ces derniers grâce à leurs pouvoirs vont
énormément influencé l'avenir des
humains en leur apportant le savoir la
technologie et la modernité c'est ce que
nous montre le trailer où les humains ne
partent de rien et ont finalement
construit une cité une cité qui
s'apparente à babylone un lieu qui n'est
pas du tout choisi au hasard car il
traduit un moment iconique de l'histoire
des éternels leur bataille contre le
déviant cros bon je vous avoue je fais
un énorme saut par rapport à ce que nous
propose le trailer mais dans une logique
de scénario babylon va symboliser pour
moi le début et la fin du film comme un
lieu
référent pour les éternels là où tout a
commencé avec la construction de
babylone et la fin du film avec une
énorme bataille pour revenir aux
éternels nous avons la présence tout
d'abord dick harris c'est un petit peu
le superman du mc eu
il est très fort il peut voler et tirent
des rayons avec ses yeux est juste à
côté nous avons sears est un personnage
normalement clé pour le film cette
dernière peut manipuler la matière et
est très proche de l'humanité un trait
de caractère que l'on retrouve dans le
trailer
quand elle dit trouver la terre
magnifique et même dans ses pouvoirs
c'est elle qui produit de l'eau dans le
trailer on est loin des pouvoirs bourrin
comme certains des ethernet
cette dernière sera un personnage clé
comme je le disais car elle va
normalement apporter une sorte de
triangle amoureux très amoureuse dick
harris ces derniers vont avoir une
histoire qui va traverser les âges
cependant elle aura comme dans les
comics une relation avec jane white man
alias black knight joué par kit
harington c'est certainement le
personnage qui m'intrigue le plus pour
le film kit harington n'est pas choisie
pour jouer le rôle par hasard car black
knight comme son nom l'indiqué est un
chevalier ces genres le meilleur épéiste
des héros marvel et y combat également à
cheval
sauf que là où c'est intéressant c'est
que jane white man est un humain comme
les autres
il excelle juste on va dire dans les
combats à l'épée sans oublier toute
l'histoire de la lignée de sa famille
néanmoins grâce à sa relation avec sears
et il doit normalement avoir des
pouvoirs par rapport à cette dernière
étant le compagnon de vie de cette
dernière justement à voir comment cela
sera traduit dans le film mais
normalement sears et retourne avec iq
harris il perdra ses pouvoirs et ses
compétences améliorée en tout cas je
pense qu'il servira de point de repère
pour nous spectateurs un peu comme quils
était en quelque sorte l'humain du
groupe des gardiens de la galaxie
composé que d'extraterrestres je pense
que ce sera la même chose ici
est ce que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire si nous revenons sur le trailer
nous avons un enchaînement concernant
et membres qui vont composer l'équipe
des éternels donc tena qui est la
guerrière badass du groupe qui se sert
d'une énergies cosmiques pour secret des
armes à jacques qui symbolise la
spiritualité capable de soigner les
humains et les éternels mais qui sert
aussi de communicante pour les célestes
faste au ski et le forgeron du groupe et
qui aurait bien fit avec tony stark
il est capable de créer tout ce qu'ils
imaginent du moment qu'ils allaient
matériaux pour sans oublier king go
capable de lancer des projectiles
cosmique et qui a fait carrière à
bollywood chose que l'on retrouve dans
le trailer et qui est fidèle à son
histoire
wright qui à la manière du rwanda à ses
débuts génère des illusions mais où le
plus intéressant c'est qu'elle est très
au fait de l'actualité de l'humanité
c'est je pense pour quoi elle parle des
avengers à la fin du trailer mais on va
y revenir
gilgamesh un guerrier légendaire mêlant
gentillesse et puissance c'est le gars
le plus fort du coup macquarie qui est
la femme la plus rapide de l'univers et
enfin druide qui contrôlent l'esprit des
gens j'espère n'avoir oublié personne
et tant qu'on parle de druide tient une
scène le concernant me perturbe pas mal
dans le trailer
la particularité de ce dernier si je ne
dis pas de bêtises et qu'il est mi figue
mi raisin avec les éternels et les
déviants il est difficile de déterminer
parfois dans quel camp il est et c'est
ce que semble traduire le trailer où
nous voyons des humains qui ont l'air
d'être contrôlées par ce dernier
king au semble même les combattre durant
cette même scène et puis on ne le
retrouve pas pendant le dernier repas
réunissant les éternels mais bon il
semble manquer aussi à jacques ou encore
macquarie donc difficile à dire
concernant ce fameux repas justement qui
fait étrangement écho à celui des
ventures premier du nom le fait que les
éternels parle des avengers n'est pas du
tout aléatoire le film d éternel vont
nous montrer l'étendue de l'histoire de
l'humanité depuis leur arrivée sur terre
et on sait à quel point les avengers ont
marqué l'histoire et marque encore
l'histoire mais justement pourquoi
n'interviennent t-il que maintenant
après ngue il existe une histoire de
comics ou les éternels ont perdu la
mémoire
comme si leur condition d'éternel
avaient été effacés je ne vois
personnellement que cette option
et cela semble être traduit par la
réaction de circé dans une grande ville
cela expliquerait pourquoi nous sommes
face à des éternels solitaire et en
tenue de civil
nous allons avoir un moment précis où
les éternels vont perdre la mémoire et
seront dispersés c'est tout bête mais je
vois mal un personnage comme king go un
éternel et défenseurs de la planète
abandonner son rôle pour devenir une
star de bollywood
bref maintenant la logique voudrait que
l'antagoniste du film soit les déviants
et je pense que nous allons en avoir
lors de la création des éternels il y a
eu également la création des déviants
les deux races sont dans une éternelle
guerres depuis leur création est là où
les éternels son beau et puissant
les déviances ont pu s'apparenter à des
monstruosités et nous en avons l'exemple
avec thanos hewitt à noces est un
déviant
il est unique il était différent des
autres habitants de titan il était
considéré comme fou avec ses idées et il
est doté d'une incroyable puissance
comme dans endgame où il se fait à lui
seul steve rogers tort et tony stark
ce qui rend encore plus bizarre sur le
pourquoi les éternels n'était pas là
sachant que la noce et un déviant leur
éternel ennemi
bref leur perte de mémoire est
obligatoire mais ce qui est très
intéressant là dedans c'est que les
déviants qui perdent généralement
toujours contre les éternels vont ici
avoir une sorte de bien d'espoir parce
que thanos a réussi à accomplir sa
mission
thanos 1 d'evian a détruit la moitié de
l'univers et a causé d'innombrables
dégâts et par rapport aux comics et
babylone
on peut s'attendre à avoir cros l'un des
chefs iconique des déviants capable de
se mesurer seul face aux éternels
il a même eu une relation avec tena dans
les comics chose que nous pourrions voir
à l'écran néanmoins à la manière de
chaque film marvel
il faut que les éternels est un ennemi
liés à leur histoire et qui les
surpassent pour nous montrer un
véritable challenge comme thor ragnarok
par exemple ouh le vilain et sa soeur
est là
qui lui met une dérouillée ou bien
docteur strange qui fait face à dormammu
un rival propre à ce personnage et son
histoire donc dans l'idée il ya de très
grandes chances que les éternels
combattent un céleste dans leurs films
les célestes sont les créateurs de ces
derniers ils sont beaucoup plus anciens
cosmique et puissant que et les éternels
sont les défenseurs de la terre c'est ce
qui les caractérise
donc il faut une entité qui menace
l'humanité là où les déviances sont
généralement plus intéressés par les
éternels eux-mêmes comme l'écrit avec
les skrull par exemple et ça tombe bien
car nos amis légaux nous aide à trouver
des indices ils ont encore une fois
reveal via un nouveau set et c'est le
céleste à raychem le juge qui a été
dévoilé on parle bien évidemment d'un
set de lego consacré aux éternels arish
mc le juge céleste qui détermine si une
espèce peut continuer de vivre ou non si
cela s'avère véritable c'est gros comme
une maison à raychem voudrait éteindre
l'humanité choses auxquelles les
éternels serait en désaccord et comme
nous l'a montré
igo il existe des célestes malveillants
néanmoins étant donné leur ancienneté et
leur as et cosmique
il y a de grandes chances car echems
soit en train de dormir et que quelqu'un
va venir le réveiller peut-être cros
pourquoi pas cependant les déviants sont
aussi les ennemis des célestes donc il
est possible que les déviances ali aux
éternels pour vaincre l'entité cosmique
enfin je voulais terminer avec un petit
mot concernant black panthères car la
météorite vibranium serait apparemment
liées justement à l'histoire des
éternels eh bien peut-être aurons-nous
des réponses dans ce film où peut-être
dans black panther 2 voilà c'est tout ce
que j'avais à dire ombragé pas de
réponse pour le moment c'est encore
beaucoup trop tôt je pense en tout cas
que c'était une bonne entrée en matière
et j'espère que vous ressortirez de ma
vidéo avec un petit peu plus
d'éclaircissement conscient concernant
les éternels n'hésitez pas à me laisser
un petit commentaire je sens que ce film
va être très particulier et très à part
par rapport à ce qu'on est habitué de
voir puis bah abonnez-vous à la chaîne
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus est
évidemment le petit concours un stand
gaming c'est important que le lionheart
soit avec vous c'était un argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]